بمساحه تجاوزت 52 الف متر مربع انتهت
امانه المنطقه الشرقيه من تنفيذ سبع حدائق
جديده وممشا بمدينه الدمام وذلك في احياء
النهضه والفرسان والروضه والشعله والروابه
حيث تقدر مسطحات هذه الحدائق الخضر بنسبه
60 في المئه ثمت الحديقه بناء على هويه
بصريه فريده بحيث تخلق بيئه حضاريه مناسبه
لجميع افراد المجتمع وتنتج عنها تجربه
تفاعليه بين جميع افراد المجتمع سواء
كانوا اطفال عوائل او حتى من فئه الشباب
تضم هذه الحدائق عددا كبيرا من المرافق
الحيويه ابرزها مناطق مخصصه لالعاب القوى
بالاضافه الى ملاعب متعدده الاغراض ومسرح
مفتوح الى جانب العاب لكبار السن ومواقف
لذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه حرصت الامانه في
مشاريعها الجديده على مواءمه الاهداف
الاستراتيجيه للبرنامج وتع النشاطات
البدنيه والرياضيه للافراد المجتمع من
خلال مضامير المشاه وزياده المسطحات
الخضراء في الحدائق لزياده نسبه المسطحات
الخضراء للفرد بالاضافه الى توفير فرص
ترفيهيه لافراد المجتمع امانه المنطقه
الشرقيه تسعى من خلال هذه الحدائق الى
تحقيق مفهوم انسنه المدن وزياده نصيب
الفرد من مساحه المسطحات الخضر وتقديم
الخدمات الترفيهيه للسكان والزوار عبر
تحقيق افضل المعايير لجوده الحياه ضمن
التنميه المستدامه التي تسعى الامانه
لتطبيقها ضمن مستهدفات رؤيه 2030 عبد
الرحمن العصيمي من الدمام العربيه